le petit homard à cinq mois il est le
seul survivant de bombardements
israéliens qui a fauché la vie de deux
mères et de leurs huit enfants
rassemblés dans une maison de gaza une
enfant de l'eau sont mohamed al hadidi
n'a plus qu'un fils un petit miraculé
comme il l'appelle ramené à la vie par
des secouristes ses quatre autres
enfants et sa femme sont toujours sous
les décombres
d'où notre sol qu'ont ils fait pour
mériter d'être bombardées sans aucun
avertissement sans qu'on leur demande
d'évacuer la maison dit il
les bombardements se sont intensifiés
dans la bande de gaza au cours des
derniers jours
chaque jour des pires en pires les
frappes aux comores et le son qui coule
les enfants de gamin de 3 et de 4 ans
qui sont sous les décombres et qu'il
soit mort et des couilles dimanche 42
personnes dont au moins huit enfants et
deux médecins ont péri à gaza
c'était après que l'aviation israélienne
est pulvérisé la tour de 13 étages
abritant les locaux de la chaîne
d'information al jazeera et de l' agence
de presse américaine associated press
les résidents du sud d'israël sont eux
aussi grandement ébranlé les groupes
armés palestiniens en particulier hamas
ont tiré plus de trois mille roquettes
en territoire israélien depuis une
semaine la majorité étant intercepté par
les boucliers de défense militaire faire
ça dans mes draps faudra continuer à se
battre tant qu'il n'y aura pas cessez le
feu à long terme 17 habitants d'israël
moi je me suis rendu à plusieurs
reprises à la frontière avec gaza eh
bien les gens me disaient moi je suis
pas en colère contre le peuple gazaoui
je suis en colère contre le hamas et je
suis en colère contre le premier
ministre netanyahu parce que ça fait 12
ans qu'il est au pouvoir il est donc
d'une certaine façon responsable de ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui pour ceux
journalistes postés à jérusalem le
premier ministre netanyahu cherche à
décimer leurs abbas là on veut finir la
guerre on
des têtes on veut des têtes ça veut dire
quoi on veut avoir par exemple le chef
politique
yark et a6 noire le chef militaire
mohamed daïf qu'israël veut détruire les
infrastructures du hamas
les rampes de lancement et ces tunnels
vous savez tout ce système très
perfectionné de tunnels où le hamas
abrite des hommes et des armes
côté palestinien la population ne semble
pas diviser pour le moment dix
journalistes de gaza à la fin de la
guerre on peut en avoir
et là on va devoir nous d'accord pas
d'accord et pendant la guerre et qu'on
peut tuer tuer tuer de l'infrastructure
et kombouare partout dans ce tourbillon
de haine et de peur
une touche d'espoir le personnel juifs
et arabes de cet hôpital prend soin de
prôner la paix et le rapprochement entre
les deux communautés
sylvain desjardins radio canada montréal